I just want to say here you are in
Holland please do not back down in my
country we have just you know had the
fabulous Governor of Kentucky say the
future of education we don't need
philosophers we need engineers and we're
going to stop funding education for
anything that's not engineering and the
hard sciences and we don't need the
philosophers and we don't need the
humanities now of course I do realize
that being human is not necessary but
the humanities are about advising you
how to be human and deepening what it
means to be human
and I think without that you can have
all the hard science you want for
breakfast but it's not a balanced diet
and also Obama keeps coming forward and
saying I want more scientists and more
mathematicians he doesn't say I want
more humanities majors and I want more
philosophers but of course they could
have helped him not greenlight torture
they could have really helped him not
decide that it was cheaper to simply
attack a few villages with drone strikes
it's not cheaper it's so much more
expensive and the famous cliche but it's
true is if you think education is
expensive see how expensive it is to
have no education and that's what we're
in the middle of America right now in my
country education has been deliberately
attacked and rolled backwards since 1980
in a systematic way in the
my state of California in 1984 the
legislators started meeting a special
committee to create new crimes so that
people could be locked up in new prisons
and to systematically shut down schools
so in some parts of California prisons
are the new schools and that was not
accidental it was organized starting in
1984 we now have in the state of
California more prisons we have built
more prisons since 1984
then mouths a tongue and Joseph Stalin
put together and we now have the largest
prison population in world history in
the state of California
we've also perfected solitary
confinement in which young gang members
are quote-unquote isolated for their own
good and have no human contact for now
seven eight nine and ten years these
people have of course lost their minds
the young people who have been released
have gone home and they're sitting in a
back room of their mother's house with
the blinds drawn down during the day and
the door shut not able to talk to anyone
it costs two hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars per year to subject a
human being to this treatment solitary
confinement and the new California
prison system but we do not have three
thousand dollars to send that person to
college to put a young person in the
California prison system costs five
times more than tuition at Harvard and
what most young people don't have is
basic opportunity to do something
interesting not something that insults
their intelligence but something that
engages their intelligence and opens a
world that is more interesting than what
surrounds them at the moment
and our rollback of education has meant
we have deprived an entire generation of
doing something more interesting than
what they're now doing and it's not that
there's nothing that needs to be done
but again we live in an amazing moment
of economic thinking anything that
actually does not need to be done there
is money available immediately anything
that urgently needs to be done has no
budget no money has been defunded the
budget has been cut or removed and I
just want to describe to you a little
bit of what I'm hoping the next stage
for education is but also how this works
in public life because it's now time for
universities to have serious roles in
public life once again because if we
leave truth-telling to the politicians
and to the legislators that will be a
problem
and so the universities now need to step
forward and have a very public phase
which is where the arts are actually
crucial because the arts are about the
ability to speak in public to act in
public and to create a dialogue and to
create a participatory shared occasion
that is able to function through
metaphor that lets everybody go to the
next step themselves or together I just
want to again underscore if more of the
political decisions that we've seen in
the last generation had been made with
artists in the room and I don't mean to
say that artists are better than other
people they're the worst artists are
just horrible and there's nothing worse
than bad art and there's a lot of it
well no there's one thing worse than bad
art and that's the bad artists who made
it but just to say I'm not making a
special case for artists being great I'm
just saying it's another sensitivity
sensibility awareness and thought
process which needs to be in the room as
decisions are being made about welfare
education war and peace about housing
and about law at the moment the law has
a very little majesty because so many
laws have been passed that are simply
offensive and it will take two
generations to remove laws that have
been passed in the last 20 years law
does not mean morally correct law means
what somebody thought they could do to
their own advantage and to disadvantage
someone else and that is the law we need
a larger picture of what law is which is
why moral philosophers are necessary
because most law is just expediency and
deliberately somebody putting their
thing
you're on the scale because they can and
we need to ask ourselves very seriously
what the structures of equality are and
could be in the 21st century we have
come from extremely unequal histories
unequal systems unequal ways of thinking
unequal categories and equality is the
urgent question the other question for
me for intellectuals is now we've had an
amazing period of critical theory in
which intellectuals have spoken in a
language that is in penetrable to the
general public
which means no one who actually votes
has read your damn book because it's
unreadable and our with deep admiration
because there's been such beautiful work
done intellectually in the last 35 years
the task of the next 35 years or 50
years is to rewrite those books in a
language that becomes part of public
dialogue what I'm saying is the real
intellectual task is to find a way to
discuss complexity in terms that are
simple with no falsification how do we
remain honest and true to genuine
complexity but express that complexity
in a way that is transparent and where
there are points of entry for an entire
range of citizens that is a serious
intellectual challenge and we need the
greatest minds to take up that challenge
of knows falsification but actually
using with discipline and precision
language that is within reach of a
majority of the citizens